first jump  yeah just a little friendly advice  just get out of my seat come on there  you go  [Music]  welcome to the last chip making the  journey to new earth  for the next six months we will blaze  across space and time  i hope it's the paradise they said it  would be  hey where you been hiding  [Applause]  i don't know what could have done this  something seems to be dissolving him  from the inside out  it's not human and i might still be out  there  it's out there we kill it  you remember how to use one of those  things  what do you think look up  light him up there are 300 000 souls on  this ship  so we're headed to new earth at the  speed of light with an  alien yeah we got it what are you gonna  do  improvise  bullets were useless what about fire  my work all right who wants barbecue  [Music]  you